if you're not getting the responses you
want from l l M's or large language
models like the model that powers chat
GPT I may know what's wrong
it might be you no no no hear me out
hear me out look you see the way that we
prompt these large language models is
very important
so prompting plays a significant impact
in the quality of the response that the
llm will generate let's take a look at
an example I'm working on a homework
assignment for my econ 101 class and I
need some help so I issue the following
prompt to a large language model
question explain the different types of
banks the llm responds with this Banks
along a river can take various forms
depending on whether they are natural or
artificial whoa oh hang on there here I
am trying to understand the difference
between a credit union and an investment
institution and it's talking to me about
Riverbanks this is an example of a
particular type of prompt and that is
called
zero shot
prompting
you're providing the model with a single
question or instruction without any
additional context examples or Guidance
the model is expected to understand and
answer the prompt without that context
and to do so it relies solely on its
pre-existing knowledge and its ability
to generalize from that knowledge to
generate a relevant and accurate
response and as you can see
it can lead to some sub-optimal
responses now bank is a homograph it has
multiple meanings one method to clear
that ambiguity up is to employ a
different type of prompting
called
few shot prompting
now here is an example of few shot
prompting so we've got question what is
the primary function of a bank answer A
bank's primary function is to accept
deposits provide loans and offer other
Financial Services to individuals and
businesses question explain the
different types of Bank with few shop
prompting the model is provided with one
or more examples to help guide its
understanding of the task at hand by
providing an example related to two
financial institutions the llm is more
likely to understand that you are asking
about types of Bank in the context of
Finance
rather than the stream at the bottom of
your garden now in this example we could
probably just have used a better zero
shot prompt like uh like explain the
different types of banking financial
institutions that probably would have
worked but
but fuchsia prompting has other
advantages too it can help an llm
understand the expected format a
response should take like this so we've
got question create a title for my web
page then a title tag with all about
Banks then question create a heading for
my article then we have an H1 title pair
with types of banks in those tags and
then we say question list the types of
Banks and here the llm May derive we are
looking for answers in HTML notation and
respond accordingly like this
now there's another way that few shop
prompting can help and that is to Aid
reasoning so let's take an example from
the paper large language models are zero
shot reasoners which was written by the
University of Tokyo and Google research
and they issued this zero shot prompt to
a large language model
question a juggler can juggle 16 Bulls
half of the balls of golf balls and half
of the golf balls are blue how many glue
blue golf balls are there the answer is
now can you figure this out
it's it's not too tricky but it was for
the llm
eight
wrong so next in the paper they tried a
few shot prompt so we start off with a
sample question and a sample completion
so question Roger has five tennis balls
he buys two more cans of tennis balls
each can has three tennis balls how many
tennis balls does he have now answer the
answer is 11. question a juggler can
juggle 16 balls and so forth
now we've shown the model what a right
answer looks like by applying addition
and multiplication to a sentence so did
the few shot prompt get us the right
answer
eight again no but by making a slight
change we can improve the reasoning of
the llm and get the right answer and we
can apply that change to either few
sharp prompts or two zero shot prompts
so what is this mysterious Edition well
it's called
chain
of
thought
or c o t and to invoke it just add
wordings such as let's think step by
step
effectively we've asked the llm to
document its thinking
we're asking to see its Chain of Thought
and here's what we get so the llm
responds to us with There are 16 balls
in total half of the balls are golf
balls that means there are eight golf
balls half of the golf balls are blue
that means there are four blue golf
boots
four golf balls that is the right answer
now this particular test was applied to
the instruct GPT model which is a couple
of years old newer models like gpt4 can
invoke mathematical reasoning without
the let's think step-by-step Chain of
Thought prompting but Chain of Thought
prompting remains a valuable tool in
prompt engineering for a number of
reasons reason number one is it
encourages the model to provide a more
detailed and specifically a more
transparent response
and an explanation of that response and
its reasoning process and this helps
users better understand how the model
arrived at a particular answer making it
easier for them to evaluate the
correctness and relevance of the
response and that's all an important
part of x a I or explainable AI
and then reason number two for Chain of
Thought prompting is that it can be used
to improve the quality of a model's
response by encouraging it to consider
alternative
perspectives
or different approaches and by asking
the model to Think Through various
possibilities it can generate more
well-rounded and comprehensive answers
which can be particularly valuable when
dealing with open-ended or subjective
questions look ultimately few shot
prompting and chain of thoughts
prompting are powerful techniques that
can be employed to improve the quality
of responses generated by large language
models by providing the model with
additional context examples or guidance
users can help the model better
understand the task at hand and generate
more accurate relevant and well-reasoned
responses
and not to mention
keep better track of how many golf balls
we're juggling
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like And subscribe thanks for watching